[Music]
this is my final question for you we
have we have time for one weird question
is do you have any movies that you
obsessively watch over and over mine is
there will be blood I watched that I
probably seen it 30 times which is the
scene
do you watch because you probably don't
watch it always in its entirety right
you watch pieces I might not make it all
the way it's a long film which are the
things that you have to hit what's the
scene that you have to hear you know
what I could do without what the sad
part when he's in the mansion alone I
cut it off early so it's just a story of
a man making a lot of money and friends
with oil and then just wins anyway
that's amazing here he reconciles with
his son Eli there's no falling that's so
good what is yours i watch old movies
from the 70s like i'll watch like the
other night i was kind of in a bad mood
and I was like I'll watch taxi driver
bit by bit didn't put me in a better
mood but the one I watched the most is
ordinary people I watched and re-watched
ordinary people uh-huh which is
basically like you know it's a terribly
terribly sad movie but I really like I
liked the way Judd Hirsch dresses
the Wardrobe is okay I make decisions
based on sweaters like if I'm shopping
for sweaters I'll make the decision in
my head I'm like with Judd Hirsch wear
this in therapy but Timothy Hutton and
if the answer is yes then bag it up
that's how I am with prospecting boots
and hats and mustaches if would Daniel
day-lewis where oh yes the answer is
almost always yes
don't become in the Revolutionary War
times that they're like the hottest part
on a guy was the calf muscle so that's
why when they would do that like at a
ball they go like this it was like check
that's basically like whipping your calf
the dick of the leg yes
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]